how much different is real-life politics
especially in the age of trump
do the abuses of power in the current
white house make house of cards seem
more like a documentary who better to
ask than the fixer himself three-time
emmy nominee michael kelly whose most
recent role was another very political
one uh he plays former acting fbi
director andrew mccabe on show
times the comey rule michael thank you
so much for joining us
oh man thanks for having me maddie good
to see you
good to see you too somebody on twitter
said to me today i must conduct the
whole interview but only calling you
doug
throughout the holiday but i won't i'll
call you michael you were famously on a
show
you were famously on a show where the
politicians their family members
their fixers their advisors were almost
all corrupt
crooked dishonest dark when you look at
the trump administration
how does it compare to frank underwood
i i'm not going to go so far as to say
they're killing people but
there's a lot of similarities it's sort
of you know we we
came onto the scene and uh during the
obama administration and we were
the crazy show right we were this
outlandish look at what uh washington
politics could be like
um and then we weren't so crazy anymore
uh
the things we were doing you know it's
had we had we
done the things that this administration
has done
um people would have said we jumped the
shark long
long before it was over
i'm sure you have the same feeling that
a lot of us have just looking at the
daily news and the revelations and the
scandals
and asking you know how can this be real
if you were working on house of cards
and they'd given you say
the trump impeachment story as the
script for an
episode wouldn't you have said this is
ridiculous no one would believe the
president does something this corrupt so
openly
so proudly just
foolishly like just the way in which he
handled it was
so poorly done uh if you're gonna do
stuff like that you have to be more like
francis underwood or doug stamper
they just don't seem to have the ability
to be
rotten and be effective and get away
with it it's
it's just absolutely incompetent can you
imagine how bad it would be
exactly you know there was a time when i
did volunteer too
uh when when he was looking for a chief
of staff and i was like you know what
for the sake of the country i will come
be your chief of staff i tweeted at the
president
uh thankfully he didn't take me up on it
i mean he goes through chiefs of staff
so quickly uh your time might come
your new series on showtime is called
the comey rule it examines the
relationship between
former fbi director james comey and
president trump you play
former acting fbi director andrew mccabe
who was later fired
on this clip we're about to play a
conversation between your character and
the character who plays
president trump quickly becomes
unpleasant have a listen
fbi people love me same feeling i get in
north carolina which i went so big
90 of the bureau voted for me who did
you vote for
mr president i've been a republican all
my life
i have voted for every republican
presidential candidate
but given the circumstances present at
the time
i didn't feel as appropriate for me to
vote in 2016.
michael what was it like as a real-life
pretty vociferous trump critic
to be speaking directly to trump as it
were
um you know watching it back there just
now and doing it that day it was all as
chilling as the first time i read it
as the first time that i spoke with
andrew mccabe about it it's
the things that he said to andrew mccabe
in that phone call you know
the scene goes on and he actually asks
andrew
what it you ask your wife what it feels
like to be a loser
you can't you can't wrap your head
around it you know it's chilling for me
to see it
again and uh to think that a president
behaves and speaks that way i i just i
can't
you know it's hard hard to watch uh
you no it must be you do a lot of
political drama house of cards the comey
rule
i saw you on the amazon series jack ryan
why is that
is that something that particularly
appeals to you that this genre
i mean it certainly does i think you
know going going back
early in my career to dawn of the dead
uh i played this hard ass
character in a crazy zombie movie but he
was kind of this hard-ass guy and uh
and i feel like the roles that i've been
offered since then especially since
um house of cards you know every every
single offseason after that show aired i
i was offered a job or at least had a
conversation with the director before i
was offered a job
uh it really changed my life it changed
my career
um and people you know wanted to see
that i remember i did that series taboo
this is a funny story i did a series
taboo and
i was doing the scene and they said uh
the director said can you just
can you lower your register a little bit
and i was like okay we did a take and
he's like can you be a little bit more
menacing and we did another take and i
was like okay so you won an 1800
doug stamper basically and uh and he was
like
yeah we just wanted a little more hard
and i'd say you meant
you mentioned doug stamper i got to ask
about doug stamp because there's a role
that's fascinated me and i love doing
that show
everyone who knows you and you know
people talk about you all
they say you're one of the nicest guys
around you're nothing like doug stamper
right
you get you get universal positive
praise from your peers
how hard is it for someone like you a
nice guy in real life to become
that character that menacing doug
stamper
uh it is it was tough um
the the writing is so brilliant though
on that show
uh that it did make it easier but
i did take steps you know i mean i did
live a normal life there in baltimore
but i kept an apartment in baltimore and
i lived in new york city my family
stayed in new york city
i would drive to baltimore and spend
four or five days there i drive home on
a weekend
and my life there was very minimalistic
the apartment was minimalistic
i just would run and and work out
and just try to you know i i'm not a
method i did learn method acting at the
actors studio
but i i didn't live it you know i could
still go to the pub and
have a beer and dinner with my
colleagues and have a good time and
and live a normal life but you do find
yourself you know
i would either drive in silence for the
three hours or i would just listen to my
lines over and over
um so you just find ways to slide into
that mentality
just back to the political scene you
tweeted uh this while president obama
campaigned
in philadelphia for joe biden yesterday
you said my heart feels so much better
thank you barack obama let's do this
america
um right now the country is incredibly
divided that division of course
preceded trump it was actually pretty
divided on obama's watch
what if anything will it take to bring
americans together do you think
i think it's it is something like uh joe
biden administration and those people
that he's surrounding himself in that
cabinet that you know he's going to fill
with competent people
and we are no longer god willing come
election day or
30 40 days but after after whatever
whatever it became
becomes possible for him to be president
um
we're not going to be constantly
smacked in the face with a tweet or just
a new piece of insanity or corruption
being dropped daily
we know this we know the man we're
getting in joe biden right we know who
he is
we know that he's not going to be like
that so
i think that in and of itself will help
start
to heal us and look joe biden uh
is a man who is known for reaching
across the aisle
if anyone is going to get it done in
this in this day and age
it's him uh because this country look
man we
i don't care what side you're on man we
got to come together this is just
this is bad this is really bad and i
look at it right now to the point where
i have an eight-year-old and 11 year old
and when the president is on television
speaking
i can't have my children watch the
television because he's going to say
something inappropriate
he is going to say something racist i'm
not calling him a racist
but he's going to say something racist
or inappropriate
and i just feel like a big calm could
come over the country
with a biden harris administration
i think you're so right there and we'll
see what happens in the debate tonight
last night we joked on this show about
how
you know donald trump said if you if you
elect biden it'll be a boring presidency
i think a lot of us want boring uh
michael kelly will have to leave it
there thank you so much for taking time
out
to come on the show